brad wright says we're going to get a
conclusion to stargate atlantis
how
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so first of all i'll give you a little
bit of an update of how stargate
atlantis ended just in case you can't
remember before we have a little bit of
a chat about how on earth we could get
some sort of conclusion to this series
and what that conclusion might look like
so at the end of the series the enemy of
the gate the hundredth episode and the
final episode of stargate atlantis an
episode that was dedicated to donnes
davis general hammond because he
died just before quite suddenly from her
heart problems we saw the wraith develop
a new super hive ship
now they got a bunch of zpm's one of my
favorite characters todd had warned the
sg atlantis crew and they were going to
go and fight the wraith now the
deadliest went in and attacked this new
super high ship they were trying to get
it before it could leave but
they lost that battle the daedalus was
very heavily damaged the hive ship got
this weird message from the episode
before from a mirror universe um and had
realized where earth was so the hive
ship was on its way a mega buffet of 8
billion humans to tuck into
on its way the apollo and the zoo
intercepted this new super high ship and
both those vessels were quickly disabled
shepard gated back to earth to tell
everybody what was going to happen and
they had a plan about getting an f302s
and trying to use nuclear weapons to
destroy this new high vessel he snuck
aboard the hive ship as it got into
earth's orbit
with the nuclear weapon in the meantime
atlantis had been flown from the pegasus
galaxy back to earth it engaged with the
hive ship in earth orbit but was pushed
back from the extreme weapons and pushed
into a decaying orbit it was going to
crash land on earth
on board the hive ship
ronan died for a bit and shepard got
aboard with the nuclear weapon
eventually destroying the hive ship from
within everybody gated out just before
it went
and everything ended up all happy except
the atlantis that was cloaked sat in san
francisco bay
that's how basically the episode ended
that's i know a very very quick synopsis
but you know what just go and watch it
it's brilliant i should also say this
episode had the highest um cgi budget
for almost any stargazing there's only
one or two episodes that even came close
to how much this episode actually cost
to make so
where are we at
we have to remember that the wraith are
still all over the pegasus galaxy there
are humans all over pikas galaxy still
being
fed upon
there was no conclusion to that battle
these have not been defeated please if
you're new to the channel like subscribe
hit the bell notification but also now
get into the comments and tell me what
do you think could happen with the
stargate atlantis do we want to see the
rafe defeated
could the wraith actually attack earth
in the new series now i think that was
going to be probably the most likely
scenario brad davis and joseph mosey
have already talked about how we want to
see a conclusion to stargate universe
but could we see as some sort of
storyline as well a conclusion to
stargate atlantis now the wraith have
already attacked earth but obviously
more than 10 years has gone by since
target atlantis ended i don't actually
think we would see stargate atlantis
return to the pegasus galaxy like it
didn't did in some beta cannon
because i think it would be too valuable
here on earth it would be moved to be
maybe somewhere like diego garcia or
something like that some base that the
americans have that's in the middle of
nowhere
that then they could basically tear the
um atlantis apart and find its um all
its mysteries
i think as an interesting storyline
might be that they actually do discover
something within atlantis because you
know they didn't search most of that
ship they were always finding new things
so maybe something really deep in the
depths of the city is discovered so
actually the earth could come under
attack again the wraith know where we
are the super high ship came here maybe
the wraith have been trying to build up
thing maybe they find more zpm's maybe
they make another run at us i don't
think stargate command would go out of
its way to engage itself with the wraith
they would not start a war with a
species in a completely other galaxy the
wraith could actually very easily become
the bad guy in the new stargate series
but i think they will try to create
something new and if we do have this
sort of storyline it would be again a
two or three episodes maybe one
interesting possibility is that maybe if
the wraith do attack the milky way or
there is some sort of engagement
that they actually instead of maybe
defeating the wraith maybe we find some
sort of genetic way of preventing the
wraith from feeding upon humans or
stopping them from requiring to feed
upon humans which is something they did
look into in stargate atlantis maybe
they succeed in that and create some
sort of weapon that again like i said
either means that the humans become
or neither edible and maybe we poison
some in some way that obviously doesn't
kill humans but stops us from being fed
upon by the wraith or that we do
something to the wraith through some
sort of weapon system that means that
they can't feed on so don't need to feed
on humanity anymore but the main thing
is like i said in the beta cannon i
cannot see atlantis returning to
the pegasus galaxy it just makes no
sense on earth it would be the most
valuable resource we had pretty much
except other than maybe the stargate
itself and the
antarctic base so
for me it's too valuable a resource it
would never get things it would just be
torn apart for research and would be one
of the main reasons how we would advance
our technology so again get into the
comments guys tell me what you think if
stargate atlantis did return how would
you want to see it
and if we did have a conflict with
wraith and we tried to resolve that
storyline how would it work
maybe we just find a way to put the
wraith back to sleep
or do something along those lines
you've always had amazing comments and
an amazing imagination should please get
into that like i said get into the
comments tell me exactly what you think
and let's start a debate how could we
see this happen
please if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you're not please consider becoming a
fully fledged member of sidetrack you
can hit the join button as always guys
please stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you